ils étaient se à avoir répondu à l'appel
des AFC du secteur éducation mariage IVG
les candidats présents pour cette soirée
ont pu exposer leur position sur ces
thématiques chè aux associations
familiales catholiqu inquiète après 5
ans de présidence François Hollande nous
avons connu beaucoup de régressions sur
d'un point de vue droit familial pouvoir
d'achat des familles et nous avons de
plus en plus de bénévoles qui désirent
s'investir politiquement dans notre
association pour faire bouger les choses
et faire en sorte que le balance reparte
dans l'autre sens pour répondre aux
différentes questions pendant 2 he un
plateau politique classé à droite Front
national républicain parti
chrétiens-démocrate seul la République
en marche faisait figure d'exception ces
échanges étaient aussi l'occasion pour
les petits candidats de faire connaître
leur proposition sur la famille nous
avons dans nos
propositions la notion de statut de la
famille c'està-dire que actuellement on
a un homme et une femme qui se marie
mais ça reste assez individuel nous nous
nous proposons un statut qui serait un
petit peu celui d'une société ou d'une
fondation il faut maintenant libérer
l'école il faut vraiment que les gens
puissent monter leur propre école que
que les parents puissent choisir leur
école et que vous verrez qu'ainsi les
parents iront nécessairement vers les
meilleures écoles et que vous aurez une
élévation du niveau et que ce sera on va
renouer avec l'excellence et ce sera au
bénéfice des enfants des familles et
donc de la nation le candidat de l'Union
Populaire Républicaine était aussi
présent alors que son parti n'a pas de
position officielle sur ces thématique
que déjà on doit récupérer les reennes
redresser l'économie c'est c'est la
moindre des choses avant de se poser les
questions sur la famille déjà que les
familles aent les moyens
financiers de pouvoir élever leurs
enfants dans de dans de bonnes
conditions la Fédération des
Associations Familiales catholiques des
yvelin rendra compte des débats
organisés d'ici quelques jours à ses
8000 adhérents une nouvelle soirée est
prévue le 1er juin à Versailles avec
cette fois-ci plusieurs candidats de la
première circonscription du département